moi je voulais parler du rapport
sénatorial sur le trafic de stupéfiant
provenance de la Guyane qui avait émis
le souhait puisque lors de la précédente
mandature il y avait une mission
d'information je crois menée par Olivier
sigoletti et dont Antoine kam était
était le rapporteur et donc qui guyanais
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle je je
suis très à l'aise pour parler de
narcotrafique et dans ce rapport donc
les les collègues regrettaient que
l'ofast en Guyane particulièrement est
éta trop centré sur le traitement
quantitatif des passeurs alors ma
question est simple pouvez-vous nous
dire si aujourd'hui le démantellement
des réseaux figurent encore parmi vos
priorités voilà merci donc sur le
traitement qualitatif plutôt que
quantitatif on a eu des renforts qui ont
été qui ont été envoyés à l'antenne au
faste de de guyan euh dans le courant de
l'année 2020 enfin fin d'année 2022 et
courant courant 2023 d'autres arrivent
là au mois de en fin d'année 2000 2023
l'objectif bien évidemment quand on a
des OPG à compétence nationale les
officiers de police judiciaire à
compétence nationale ce n'est pas
seulement de traiter le phénomène des
mules bien sûr il faut le traiter et les
antennes les équipes de l'antenne de
l'antenne au fast guyan sont là sont là
pour ça
euh mais on doit également avoir du
temps enquêteur pour conduire des
enquêtes sous l'autorité de la JS de for
de France notamment ou sous l'autorité
de la la junalco euh parce que traiter
le phénomène des mules simplement par
l'interception de passeur c'est
parfaitement insuffisant pour démeler un
réseau et ce n'est que le travail
judiciaire en profondeur qui permettra
d'attaquer les les organisations les
organisations criminelles